what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so normally Fridays are reserved
for full story videos right like we keep
things isolated to just like full
stories from marvel pudding like entire
story arcs into a singular video
uploading them and calling em a day but
this is Batman number 50 this is this is
Batman number 50 and this is a huge
moment if I'm being honest with you guys
I would say Batman number 50 is probably
more significant than actually comics
1000 here's a reason why I'm sure comics
1000 was inevitable right as long as
they actually comic publications went on
eventually it would happen but the idea
of Batman getting married that was never
an inevitable thing it was never
something that was destined to happen
it's something someone chose to do and
this instance Tom King you know I've
heard different reviews I've heard mixed
reviews on Tom Kings Batman run let me
tell you guys something I feel like Tom
King's Batman run is just as good as
Scott Snyder's run it's one of the best
Batman runs ever made like it is like
like if I had to create a hierarchy I'd
probably put Dennis O'Neil Neal Adams
and then probably Tom King / Scott
Snyder it's it's an amazing run and they
grant more submit like third cuz I
thought his run was okay um but still
like like it's an incredibly well done
thing and here's a funny thing we're
only halfway through we're only part way
through the entire Batman run of Tom
King so initially what this does is it
kind of leads to like the fruition right
like this whole idea of Batman getting
married and this has been drawing on for
quite some time
and in truth this has been going on long
before Tom King's run on Batman and
that's one of the cool things here and
it's one of the things that he points
out initially just kind of have like
Batman sort of giving you know given
given the business to a kite man which I
don't okay I wanna be honest guys if I'm
Batman
in kite Mans in Gotham City I would just
let him function I would just really
he's awesome like I'm gonna like hype
man just do his own thing he's just like
hype man oh yeah like I'm just gonna
like cry man go and do his own thing
because because it's cool and he's an
awesome guy but then we switch over to
Porky's bar and Porky's bar just has
this guy like this judge you know Judge
Wolfman and he's just kind of there you
know guys drunk as hell but he's just
there and he's basically snatched up by
Batman and then you switch over to Holly
Robinson now Holly Robinson
I feel like deserves a little bit of an
explanation here because she's a
character that's really kind of bounced
around over the years so Holly Robinson
is not an original Batman creation
instead she came out as part of Frank
Miller's Batman year one now for those
you guys you don't know what that means
following crisis on Infinite Earths
because Batman sales have been slumping
pretty badly DC didn't know if that make
it hold his own title and so the idea
was instead of just like jumping
straight into a reboot
I wanted to test the waters and see if
people would buy a Batman story that was
totally different from like the 19 the
1960s version of his character even a
1970s version of his character and so
when Frank Miller was brought over to DC
to write The Dark Knight Returns I mean
it sold like gangbusters and so from
there then DC decided to give him an
origin story and that's where you get
Batman year one for the post-crisis
landscape so in reality if you really
wanted to read Batman
you know chronologically starting from
the very beginning after crisis on
Infinite Earths in like 1985 you just
start with Batman year one and then just
work your way forward because that's the
origin story of his character but Holli
was introduced as this girl who was
basically a juvenile working the streets
and was ultimately rescued by Selina
Kyle now over the years and as you go
through with your DC Comics she's never
been a huge character saved for Catwoman
vol 3 and Catwoman vol 3 she actually
took over the title and the reason why
was because that followed Infinite
Crisis but with that in mind Holly's
really like rocks and waned over the
years but the overall gist of this is
that from Batman year one going into you
know various stories future stories she
always kind of played like an on-again
off-again sidekick to Catwoman sometimes
she played the role of Catwoman other
times she walked away from Catwoman
entirely she married a super-rich guy at
one point she was she actually lived
with Harley Quinn for a while she was
one of those characters that kind of
bounced around but she was never really
on the same level it's like poison ivy
Harley Quinn and Catwoman she was just
kind of like the odd man out and so
because of that um for those who are
very who are very vested in the Catwoman
mythos they're well aware of who Holly
Robinson is but if you don't really know
who she is she's just a really good
friend of Selina Kyle from here what we
end up doing is and this is something
that's kind of cool here we get these
small little letters he's small a little
like one page letters that they write to
each other and these are really designed
to kind of run over the idea of Batman
and Catwoman this is a very very
important thing because one of the first
things this establishes is that when it
comes to the Catwoman mythos and when it
comes to her relationship with Batman
that Batman
you know saw her as a villain he kind of
saw her as a villain only at the outset
and only in the beginning he basically
stopped her from thwarting a robbery
where she was dressed up as an old woman
what is time began to progress Batman
started to fall in love with her and
that's the reason why he always seemed
to take it easier on her than he did on
other criminals at the same time it's
really cool because it's hits at the
idea that for him you know not to you
know no pun intended it was like a
cat-and-mouse game it was Batman chasing
her her getting away and so it was
really more of like Batman's way of
courtship if there
was such a thing and so where you end up
having the two of them going about and
doing their own thing this is really
designed to hit home with the fact that
while they're facing off against various
villains and they're defeating various
villains and so on and so forth they are
very much a team they are very much sort
of working together so what is up
happening here is we end up finding out
the Selina Kyle had basically broken or
at least it seems like Selina Kyle had
broken Holly Robinson out of jail she
was basically the one that got him at it
or got her out of there and in turn
brought her to Wayne Manor because she's
going to be the witness on Catwoman's
side for the marriage she's gonna have a
Bruce likewise Bruce Wayne himself needs
a witness but this is what's this is
what we one of the coolest parts of the
story Bruce Wayne could have witnesses
in a myriad of different ways he could
grab Tim Drake he grabbed Dick Grayson
aah Duke Duke Thomas he could grab Hutt
even Damian Wayne or like Jason Todd but
he doesn't the person he gathers is
Alfred and the reason why is because
Selina Kyle in Holly Robinson weren't
like the one-two punch of like the
Gotham thievery world for years and
years and years and so when it comes to
that man and Alfred nicest Anna says you
were the first one like you were the
first person that I came to and said I
want to be Batman you were there when we
were building the suit you were there we
were getting the gear we were buying
everything we needed when we were
fashioning the bad cape you've been
there since the very very beginning and
even before when you've raised me as a
kid so you understand my mission better
than anybody else even if you don't
necessarily agree with it wholeheartedly
because you understand what happened
that led me here and it makes the most
sense that Alfred would be his would
would be his his you know witness would
be his best man basically because in
this situation when you have Alfred he's
essentially the father figure of Bruce
Wayne it's really you know he's really
the only father Bruce is known ever
since Thomas died and so it makes
perfect sense and it's a beautiful
moment because that's what we would
expect it would be like a son asking his
father to be his best man at a wedding
it just works
and so from here is it's really kind of
funny because when you know Calvin was
getting dressed and when Bruce Wayne's
getting dressed they really kind of hate
it
Batman's like yes I'm you know Bruce
Wayne's like I'm Batman you know I run
around and I do things I do not go to
socialite parties I hate these things
but like with Selina Kyle it's the same
way she's like she's like I don't really
like putting on these kind of outfits I
do it when I'm committing a crime but
I've left my own devices I would never
wear this and that's why I like that
it's almost like they're so perfect for
each other and so what is up happening
is you actually have Holly who sits down
and starts to talk to Selina Kyle and
this is kind of a cool moment here
because when Holly's talking to Selina
she really kind of shines a light on
Bruce in a way that that Selina never
really thought
before and that's important because it
changes the way people view other people
especially when it comes to marriage and
when you're so caught up in the whole
marriage ceremony and and you know how
how crazy everything can be and Holly
kind of me kind of murmurs and says you
know it's amazing that you're marrying
Bruce because it's what he meets like
Bruce needs the happiness that you'll
bring him because for him it seems like
the only way he can thrive as Batman is
to be miserable and to be angry and
that's why things are so cool here is
because it's a way for Bruce to kind of
walk away from the Batman mantle it's a
way for him to leave the Batman mythos
and in reality it seemed like it was
only ever a matter of time it seemed
like it was only ever a matter of time
before Bruce Wayne walked away and
someone else took his place that Bruce
would eventually go on and and do his
own thing and so following this what
they end up doing is actually in this
kind of a funny thing they're actually
driving on O'Neil Avenue again like
Dennis O'Neil Neal Adams one of the most
significant Batman runs of all time
there's a small little tribute to the
contributions they've made to the Batman
mythos but as they're going through the
idea is that they're gonna meet at the
at the South Tower which is like the
first time or the place they were when
they were first like you know intimate
basically when they first like basically
solidified their love for each other and
so it's so it's a really interesting
thing and this is a really beautiful
thing because what you end up having is
this amazing conversation that goes on
between Holli and Catwoman and Bruce and
Alfred and they basically say like we
wrote letters you know like like I wrote
a letter telling her everything
tell E telling her everything you know
everything I see everything I love about
her everything I care about about her
all that kind of good stuff
so again it's a really beautiful moment
here because Bruce it's kind of funny
because Bruce never really seemed the
way he was written never really seemed
like the kind of care that would be able
to convey his thoughts in a romantic
sense which is ironic because he's one
of the smartest men in the world and the
way he's written is he's so articulate
and intelligent but somehow not able to
voice those emotional feelings and again
it works because when you're when you're
Bruce Wayne and you're Batman and your
life is governed by vengeance and you've
always kind of kept emotion at bay what
happens when you let emotion overtake
you it almost seems like you would allow
yourself to lose control and Bruce Wayne
never lets himself lose control the
downside to all this is that Selina Kyle
has been thinking about everything
Holly's told her and so Selena Kyle is
not at South Tower Selina Kyle is at
Kane Plaza and the reason why Selina
Kyle's a clean at Kane Plaza is because
she leaves Bruce Wayne at the altar and
it's like oh my god it's Judas okay it's
the saddest thing it's the saddest thing
Tom King I've actually pissed at Tom
King
I'm so mad it's so cool I mean it's but
it's beautiful though because it's like
that man can never find happiness like I
mean it's it's tragic and it's sad but
it's like Bruce Wayne will never get
married
Bruce Wayne will never find romance that
he'll never find love because he's not
meant for it and that's what's so tragic
about it and that's what that's what
kind of makes it work is Bruce Wayne has
to be Batman
he can't be Batman and be a husband at
the same time because what that means is
he'll have something to lose that's what
that means
but I would argue that in reality I
think Bruce Wayne being married would
make him a better Batman not necessarily
from a sense of compassion but because
he does have something to lose he'll
fight all the harder to keep it and
that's why I think it would make him a
much much much much better Batman
because he would he would see Gotham in
a different light but again it's it's
it's it's sad but it's gorgeous
because in reality it just kind of hits
home with the idea that like Bruce can't
be happy Selina Kyle left him and the
whole idea was that in Selina Kyle's
mind Bruce Wayne has to be miserable in
order to be Batman it's one of these
things where she's kind of doing what's
best for Bruce and so this is kind of
funny here though because remember we're
partway through Tom King's run so it's
not like we know exactly what's gonna
happen it's only this is the end of it
he's like yep and we're done sorry guys
Bruce is gonna be miserable forever it
could very well be that this is all a
ruse but the other reason why is because
what we end up finding out here is that
Holly Robinson it seems like she was
basically busted out of Gotham out of
Arkham Asylum not by Selina Kyle but by
Bane and like the whole idea of planting
seeds of doubt in the mind of Selina
Kyle was all done by Bane it was
orchestrated by him to basically say
like you're gonna plant these seeds of
doubt you're going to essentially put in
the - Selina Kyle she cannot marry
Batman if she marries Bruce Wayne he
won't be able to be Batman again and
it'll sucessfully like destroy Gotham
City it'll it'll it'll come crumbling
down because the one person keeping the
forces of evil at bay has retired and
walked away
and so it's like Bane really from like
behind the scenes seems to have
orchestrated this whole thing now I say
seems because we don't know with an
absolute certainty but it is an amazing
reveal because if it's true if it's true
that Bane orchestrated all of this then
hot damn this really makes Bane one of
the best villains ever it is a genius
move literally break Bruce Wayne
emotionally mentally break him down in
every conceivable way
so again amazing story absolutely
amazing and I'm really excited to see
what happen
but if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
you